- Sony just isn't stopping
when it comes to new
camera releases this year.
This is one that I'm
really excited to show you
because right now,
this is the world's smallest,
lightest, full frame camera body,
with interchangeable lenses
and this new color option.
(indistinct)
(upbeat music)
This is the all new
Sony a7C Compact Camera.
This is actually an entirely
new category for Sony,
is the compact camera line.
Now this camera is full frame.
Starting price is 1799 for the body
and 2099 with an all new 20
to 60 millimeter F4 zoom lens.
They're also coming out
with some new, smaller,
compact lenses to go with this.
Because this is so light,
you wanna have a nice
light lens to go with it.
I know that it's incredibly overwhelming,
the amount of cameras out there,
especially just in the Sony family,
but when creators start
looking for that real first
mirrorless camera to upgrade to,
I'm so excited that this is now an option.
What's the lowest cost
I can get for a camera
without sacrificing too many features?
Is a question that I get so often.
And I'm always on the
hunt for that answer.
I used to make a ton of travel content
and the camera that I would mostly use
was the Sony a6500,
but this would have been the camera
that I would have gravitated towards,
if this was out back then.
Now I know that the new Sony
a7S is coming out very soon,
and that will be my main camera of choice,
but that camera is very expensive
and it is a higher end production camera.
And it's not for everyone.
We almost always have a
second camera on shoots,
and because this is so light,
this is going to be
perfect to put on a Ronin
or to use on our lower sliders,
or even just to use as a second
off camera angle like this.
Let's also just come back to the fact
that this is a full frame camera.
A lot of the previous mirrorless
cost efficient cameras have
the smaller APS sensor.
So this will let you
use full frame lenses,
and this will significantly
improve your photo
or video quality, especially
when shooting in low light.
And
have I showed you this?
It's got the flip out screen.
This is something that is
going to make everyone's lives
so much easier.
This was the one deciding factor of why
a lot of people ended up
not getting a Sony camera,
is because when you are
vlogging and filming yourself,
being able to have that
flip out screen is amazing.
Now they tried to compensate
for that by the 6400
having a flip up screen.
But when you have a camera
that has interchangeable lenses
and a hot shoe for audio,
you're gonna wanna put
a microphone on this.
And when you put a microphone
on this flip up screen,
just take a guess what happened?
(camera thuds on the table)
Spoiler alert.
You couldn't see the screen.
Thankfully, a lot of these cameras
do have really good onboard audio,
so it wasn't always necessary to have.
When that with a7S III with a
flip out screen was announced,
(Justine's hand thud on the table)
that's it, it's a game changer.
Now the size comparison is
what I really wanna show you guys.
This is the Sony a7 III,
this is what I pretty much use right now
for shooting everything.
In between there is the smaller sensor,
the Sony a6400.
So here they all are side by side.
And the biggest thing
about this is the fact
that this is a new compact form factor,
as opposed to a 7 III.
So the a7S III is a little
more like this form factor,
it is heavier.
So they've also moved the lens
piece over here to the left,
so it doesn't mimic more of the a6400
and more in this alpha line.
This just feels so huge at this point.
I mean, you guys can see
the size difference in the sensor here.
I also really like the
new body that they have
for this compact camera,
this silver kind of reminds me more
of like a vintage camera,
but it just looks slick,
it looks updated.
This looks like a real 2020,
well, don't say it looks like 2020,
but I'm just saying like
a camera up at the time,
like an updated look.
A nice new modern feel.
It almost kind of looks
like a carbon fiber finish.
This does also come in
a black version as well,
but I really do like the silver.
I think a lot of people
are going to be into that.
Do you like the silver?
- [Tyler] Yeah!
- Tyler's into it.
It's cool.
- [Tyler] You know why?
- 'Cause it looks like an
old film camera, right?
(laughing together)
Jenna is FaceTiming me.
Oh my God, is it an emergency?
It's gotta be an emergency.
Hello?
- [Jenna] What are we
gonna do about the podcast?
- What's wrong?
Do you maybe see this before?
- [Jenna] Oh my God,
yeah, it's nice.
I used it, it's crispy.
What do you think of where
that menu button is located?
- Oh, menu button?
(phone beeps)
That was a really great chat.
I like that they moved
the menu button right here
to the center,
look, if you can't find the menu button,
you're definitely not looking hard enough.
Oh, menu button.
(upbeat music)
So the headphone jack, we have USB-C,
micro HTMI, SD card slot,
and a microphone input.
The a7S III does have an
all new updated menu system.
This one does not, unfortunately,
because that menu system is really,
really cool.
Someone is cutting grass.
(machinery whirring in the background)
Here's where the battery goes.
And boy, am I excited that they decided
to cut the grass right now.
So this will shoot 4K, 30 and 24.
And in 1080 you can do 24, 30,
60, and 120.
This also has S and Q,
which we use a lot,
especially for doing time
lapses or slow motion videos.
It'll automatically
perform them into a video.
So you don't have to be
messing with a bunch of photos
to create a time lapse,
it will do it all automatically
for you in camera.
So this is the old battery,
and this is the new ones,
this is the Z-series.
And this thing is so much better
than these older, smaller ones.
We would go through so many
batteries during a day,
that I probably have 45 of these.
Crazy.
The good thing though,
is at some point during
my a7S II shooting days,
I got one of the AC adapters
and that's been amazing.
But now with this and
some of the newer cameras,
like the A7 III that we're using,
and the new a7S III,
you can actually power
those through USB-C,
and that is just,
I mean.
incredible.
♪ Smiling to some strangers ♪
♪ Swinging on my feet ♪
♪ Then I see the moonlights
sparkling in your eyes ♪
♪ All my body's frozen
and my soul's on fire ♪
♪ Just follow me baby ♪
♪ Pulling at me with a foxy move ♪
♪ I gently come over ♪
- It does have real time
auto-focus tracking, real time.
I auto-focus and and add a lot of focus,
which, you know,
we definitely use that
quite often with Maddie.
So we're now out here in Santa Monica,
taking some photos of videos.
This is where I always come
to do our test shoots because
it's usually a really nice view.
But the air quality basically
in all of the West coast is
pretty terrible, today included.
So I'm gonna try to get
you guys some footage
so you can see what this looks like,
but it's not very nice out today.
This is shooting in 4k,
and one of my favorite things
about the new updated Sony's
is the fast auto-focus.
Are you ready Tyler?
Okay, ready?
Was it fast?
(upbeat music)
How's that focus?
I better put this away
before I stabbed myself or you.
(gravel crunching underfoot)
Okay, let's do a slowmo test.
(upbeat music)
So this doesn't do 4K 120 or 240,
like the new the new a7S III,
but this still does do HD 120 and S and Q.
So that was an example of that.
What's next?
Should we take some photos?
Jenna, you wanna take some photos with me?
Okay, cool.
Photo test.
(upbeat music)
Now audio is something that
you should always keep in mind
when creating content,
and to help you monitor that
there is a headphone jack.
My favorite thing though,
is the built in hot shoe.
This is the XLR setup
that we use in almost every single video.
We use the Sennheiser
AVX wireless microphones.
So I'm wearing one right now,
right here, hello.
And this is going right
into the Sony a7 III
that we're filming with.
This is the setup that we use
for pretty much every video
that we shoot when we're out and about
or sitting here at the desk.
I love having a wireless mic on,
and we usually just use
the shotgun for backup.
Now, if you don't go
the wireless love route,
making sure you have a great
shotgun mic is very important.
There are lots of options out there,
like some of these,
when it comes to getting
external microphones,
that's also incredibly overwhelming.
These are the two that are my go-to's
when I'm shooting with Sony cameras.
This little guy is the ECM-XYST1M,
this is gonna be a quiz later,
so make sure you remember that.
This is the one that I've been using
pretty much the longest.
It's great because it's super small.
It does have a little shock Mount.
So if you are vlogging and
moving it around a lot,
pretty stable.
The one thing that I just noticed
as I was shaking this around,
the a7S III has
these added little sound
dampening technology?
I don't know, I think it just made these
a little bit more stiff.
But you can't hear them
on the camera, whereas this,
they don't have that.
So normally what I do is
I either take these off
or I will tape them so that you don't hear
that rattling around in the
body when you're filming.
But this little microphone is great.
You can do stereo.
You can move those around
depending upon what you're doing.
Whereas this one is the,
what kind of crazy name did they give you?
The ECM-B1M.
Now this microphone I really like,
this one is a little bit more advanced
and it's also way more expensive.
So if you are looking to cut costs,
definitely recommend this one.
Do we remember what that one was called?
No, I've only been using it for 6 years.
Yeah, look at that.
Hey guys, what's going on?
This is a vlog,
a vlog, Jenna.
- I'm tryna get the cheese.
- We're sitting outside of the
street having a meal because
that's what you do now here in 2020,
you can't go inside restaurants,
but you can sit outside on
the really clean street
where people used to park.
- I thought you're gonna
say something else.
- Well, they also do that as well,
but
I don't know.
I am loving this camera though.
It's pretty nice.
- It's pretty great.
- We're talking to our friend Faruq
and he said that this is kind of like
the Sony a7 III,
with an a6500 body.
Could not be more correct.
- Yeah, actually.
- Boy is it quite out here,
I'm having a,
- It's relaxing.
- fine time, relaxing time having my meal.
Oh!
(beeps)
My biggest complaint with
some of the smaller cameras
from Sony in the past
were the smaller batteries that they used.
You'd have to carry around
so many of these extras
just to make it through the day or shoot.
This one though,
uses the new updated Z-batteries,
which will give you up to 140
minutes of movie recording
or 740 images,
which is great news because
this also doesn't have
a recording limit for video.
There's a new F4 20 to 60 millimeter
that I'm really excited to try out.
Sadly, I don't have it with me here yet.
Normally for vlogging,
you want a really wide angle.
And since this is starting at 28,
that's not very wide,
but I do think this will give you
a nice range for most situations,
if you're only heading out with one lens,
but it's also nice because
if you do put it on a tripod,
you will get that extra
depth with this lens.
And of course it has a flip out screen,
so you'll be able to see yourself
and you'll be able to
make sure you're in frame.
So obviously we can use
any other full-frame lenses
that we have.
And we have been shooting
with Sony quite a while.
So guess what?
We've got plenty of lenses to use.
So-
- [Jenna] No, no, no.
- What, no, no, no, what?
Oh my God.
I just want you to know that I actually,
for a second,
forgot that there was a flip out screen,
because I'm so used to
when I grab a Sony camera
that this is not- (gasping)
The amount of years that we've vlogged
with a Sony mirrorless camera.
I was just kind of crossing our fingers,
hoping that we were in frame, countless.
You guys just don't know
how good you have it now.
You've vloggers of today.
We were in struggle city, back then.
I'm just in the shot,
I can zoom out,
we can see Tyler in the shot.
- Like this is, (gasps)
I wanna go on another road
trip and make a fun video.
- Can't go anywhere on the West coast,
we gotta go inward.
- Well where do we go?
- Arizona?
Utah?
- I would go to either.
Where should we go guys?
Where's safe?
We'll be wearing our masks.
- I keep getting pushed Wyoming a lot,
I've never been.
- [Justine] It's where
Mike Posner is right now.
- Wyoming?
Let's ask him how it is.
- I see it on his Instagram.
So the sun's starting to go down.
Should we get a time lapse
S and Q one frame a second.
- [Jenna] Sure.
- Alright.
(gentle instrumental music)
I'm not gonna say that
this is the best scenery
that we've ever time lapsed,
but at least we'll get to see a cool demo,
and see how it works.
- It's probably not the best time lapse
that we're ever going to do,
but at least we get to see how it looks.
- [Justine] Did you just say what I said?
(Jenna laughs)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I look forward to seeing
what you all think about
this camera and the fact
that Sony is creating an
entirely new compact category.
If you guys are new here,
be sure to subscribe,
hit the bell,
so you'll be notified
when I post your videos.
I have tons of them coming up.
So be on the look out.
And with that,
I'll see you guys in the next video.
(gentle pian music)
(beeps)
- [Justine] You were in S and Q.
- [Jenna] You handed it to me.
- Yeah, I know.
It's weird that you didn't change it.
- It's weird that I didn't change it.
I don't remember how to make a video.